foreign
[Music]
remembering when we could land in any
old weather
singing nothing so wrong that the right
song can't make it better
but when will the aerosols fly through
the stage lights towards the front row
of my neck starting into Wonder in
hold them pattern
circling around
won't you hold me darling till the
wheels touch down
[Music]
hearing your arms of course of alarms
sounding like
Vespers
your lips to my ears don't forget we're
alone in there
together
gloried every true love as it once was
as it is now and just might have to be
forever
Circle and around hold me and hold you
darling till the wheels down
[Music]
oh
me darling what the world burns down
[Applause]
thank you